good morning John I'm a really big fan
of a YouTube channel called technology
connections where a guy talks about
people movers and toasters and just all
of the bits and pieces that make our
world work we did a video recently on a
piece of failed technology call the flex
play DVD the whole video super worth
watching but here's a quick summary flex
play DVDs were a way to rent a DVD
without needing to return them they were
sealed in an airtight bag when opened a
chemical in the DVD would begin reacting
with the oxygen in the atmosphere and
after 2 days of that the DVD would be
unplayable I actually have right here
the very DVD that he used in that video
because I deemed him and he sent it to
me because I want to do an experiment so
flex play was a bad idea for a bunch of
reasons the reason we think it's a bad
idea the reason we all hate it is
because it seems extremely wasteful
right you have created a whole DVD just
to intentionally destroy it there was a
ton of backlash people protested outside
of the stores that sold and I'm here to
tell you today that that that was
actually fine but it also gives us a
whole heaping helping of insight into
how we imagine waste and why we do a bad
job of it so let's do my experiment
let's put the Flex play DVD here on a
scale and see how much it weighs 16
grams what about this plastic that kept
my Metamucil safe when it was shipped to
me by amazon.com what about this sugar
water bottle that has the name vitamin
in it so that I think that it's healthy
or something what about this coffee cup
that I literally took out of my garbage
can because I didn't think at all about
throwing it away now you might be saying
yourself that Hank the DVD has more than
just plastic and I just got whatever
that shiny stuff is right that shiny
stuff yeah and a heck of a lot less of
it than is in this can now I'm not
saying that all these plastics have
identical resource costs and lifespans
they don't when somebody says like just
throw away the DVD like my brain doesn't
protest to that idea because I'm like
intricately familiar with the lifecycle
of polycarbonate so why why does my
brain freak out about throwing away a
DVD but not about throwing away a
plastic I think there's two reasons
first we have been taught that DVDs are
valuable the inventors of flexplay we're
imagining DVDs as what they practically
are which is a container that holds
media just like this is a container that
holds sugar water but up until flexplay
the people selling DVDs were making the
case that they were unexceptional
experience that they were almost a
luxury product I knew that DVDs were
actually weight cheaper or would at
least become way cheaper to manufacture
and VHS tapes and indeed they are far
less resource-intensive than VHS tapes
but they were shiny and they put them in
big sturdy cases that are actually way
bigger than they need to be which
actually use far more plastic than the
DVD itself and it worked we see them as
valuable even if they are just plastic
with some foil inside and second its new
when we first started getting bottled
water people freaked out about all the
plastic that was going into this and it
always struck me as a little bit strange
that we didn't like have a commensurate
freakout about like the plastic bottles
that contain a product that is far worse
for humans and for the environment than
water coke after all it's just water
with a bunch of like really resource
intensive mega crops put inside of it in
response to that backlash a lot of
bottled water actually now comes in
flimsier thinner bottles with smaller
caps that don't use as much plastic joke
still comes in a very fancy bottle to
give us the impression of a high quality
experience this plastic is even thicker
because it's supposed to be an even more
high quality experience we rebelled
against plastic being used for bottled
water because to our brains everything
that was the way that it is when we were
kids is kind of just the way it is it's
much easier to question new things than
to question things that have always been
that way that's a problem especially
when it comes to waste because I'm not
saying it's okay to make disposable DVDs
it's not but we should probably like
think about throwing away a DVD every
time we buy a bottle of coke because in
terms of waste those things are about
the same this video brought to you by
coca-cola hell no it's not John I'll see
you on Tuesday two things one I
accidentally uploaded a Hanks Channel
video to vlogbrothers and it was over
four minutes so I have another
punishment brewing and two if you're up
for a more in-depth conversation about
the environmental footprint of these
objects and materials come on over to
Hanks channel